[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up guys and welcome to
today's video so i've decided to make
the next load of my videos
basically a series about some of the
most common mistakes and errors that i
see people making
when it comes to martial arts training
and naturally some of these are
obviously going to cross over into areas
of general fitness and things like that
as well
so i'm sure it will be very beneficial
for you now i find that often kind of
pointing out what not to do to people is
a really good way of keeping mindful
going into training so that you know
what to do instead these videos will be
appearing mostly on my personal channel
at youtube.com
grantstevensma so please head over there
and subscribe i'm now creating regular
content there as well as my instagram
channel but with that being said if
there's a topic that you think would be
really valuable to people
just let me know and i will see if i can
create an episode around that as well
so this first episode is going to be
about the common mistakes when training
on the heavy bag now the reason i wanted
to create an episode upon this topic
specifically is i see so much
really questionable form you could call
it different gyms that i train at that i
thought this
topic in this area warranted an episode
all to itself now the benefits of using
the heavy bag are just insane and hit so
many areas that exceed way out of just
combative arts it strengthens numerous
muscles of the torso as well as building
powerful shoulders as well as being a
full body resistance cardio workout
improving mobility and proprioception
all at the same time
but in order to really reap the rewards
of those benefits in their fullest
capacity we need to know how to work the
bag effectively and it'll become clear
as i approach the numerous points in
this video that there's a kind of
optimal balance which is the area you
want to focus in
to make using the bag as effective as it
can be for you now starting at point
number one and that's just basically
that there's some people
out there who have absolutely no
business hitting the bag at all
meaning that they're a complete beginner
with very little experience and trying
to go full power on the back this is
actually something that's really
dangerous to do and more often than not
these are people with a huge chip on
their shoulder who are trying to apply
maximum power to their already
anti-technique
now there was a guy at the foundry gym
in warsaw the other day which is
somewhere i trained quite regularly
my friend vaughan calls these people
jabronies and basically it's the kind of
people who
you will spar against and within 30
seconds of the round they'll just kick
you in the ball straight away so there
was this guy that was basically
roided out of his mind and for some
reason decided that he in the middle of
everybody training he was going to
sprint over to one of the big heavy bags
and he tried to deliver this
like flying knee to the bag which
resulted in him just kind of rolling off
the bag and actually falling onto his
back
meaning that everyone in the gym kind of
just stopped what they were doing and
stared at him and it was
it was just really cringe-worthy so
don't be one of those people before you
go into the bag you should have a good
grasp of technique and know how to punch
before trying to apply more power to
techniques
and it's that thing of basically just
trying to be too advanced without having
that foundation so
until you've basically got your really
foundational techniques down you want to
just work on those so this isn't just a
tip for beginners either there's also a
lot of people who
already are quite used to training and
stuff who could really do with going
back to the basics and kind of working
on their technique and their foundation
a little bit more
pushing the bag with your punches
instead of snapping the punches off the
bag and this one can be
quite difficult for people to understand
especially when they're just starting
out
and the reason for that is the seemingly
paradoxical way in which you have to
twist at the waist
push your shoulders forward in order to
apply power so i noticed that when i've
coached people to twist their body more
in punching combos especially when
throwing across for instance when i say
this and explain there's kind of more
that they could be getting out of that
punch they sometimes begin pushing the
bag rather than
snapping the punches off of the back so
the power in the strikes comes from the
transfer of energy throughout the entire
body starting with the feet that
eventually discharges through the fist
at the end so the punches have already
been set into motion about 85 percent
before the final
extension of the arm and this is the
same with kicking techniques as well
although it's less spoken about
if you want to know more about this
topic in depth i did quite an extensive
video on this topic which i will list in
the description below the next part is
about falling into the pitfall of having
the heavy bag as the only thing that
you're using to train yourself
now i think part of the reason for this
is because hitting the bag is really fun
to do
and it also feels great you get a good
workout all of those endorphins are
released and things like that when
you're doing it
but you need to remember that for
martial artists there are a vast array
of different areas to training even pad
work with a partner is more dynamic
because the partner is able to throw
strikes at you to initiate you to move
around when you're training together the
heavy bag is obviously completely
stationary and motionless whereas an
opponent is dynamic and obviously moves
around a lot not only that but they can
also strike back towards you and learn
to read your
patterns so there's just so many
different variables to take into account
even if you have absolutely no desire to
become a competitive fighter as a
martial artist
i think sparring can improve your skill
level just a hundred fold and in my
opinion is much better endurance
training
than hitting the bag or anything else
for that matter because you're forced to
keep fighting against your opponent
there's no way you can just stop like
when you use the bag for instance
because if you do that you're just gonna
get knocked down the next point is about
applying
power into every single strike that you
throw which just makes you completely
one dimensional now this is something i
see quite a lot and i guess it depends
on
what you're actually using the heavy bag
for if you're doing like high intensity
rounds of 30 seconds or something for
developing fitness then that's okay
but if you're using the heavy bag like
most people to kind of develop
and work on your combative art then you
want to think of it more like a game of
chess
where you're carefully selecting the
movements in this case the punches
that you want to apply power to nobody
can go for 12 rounds on a bag with every
single
shot with full power and intensity as
well and if anyone tells you they can
they're either not throwing enough
strikes or they're just flat out lying
and this is how you're obviously going
to fight somebody as well you don't just
go and blast people
with a flurry of full power shots you
kind of pick the shots that you're going
to use carefully you use certain strikes
like your jab to cause a reaction in
your opponent to set up subsequent ones
and so on so you can imagine trying to
apply max power to every single
jab you do for instance not only is it
going to tie you fast but it's going to
leave you in a compromised position for
your next strike
because of the disruption in your center
of gravity that's required to apply that
power again i think this is just one of
those ego trip things where it screams
just a lack of experience when you see
people training like this
now this next point is the opposite of
the last one and that's not applying
enough
power into your strikes so there's too
much power and then there's not enough
power remember i spoke about the optimal
balance at the beginning of this video
and a lot of this just comes down to
actually not really trying hard enough
unfortunately
it's natural that if you're not applying
enough power into at least a portion of
the total strikes you execute then your
body isn't going to benefit from the
conditioning that it otherwise would do
if you were doing that
it's something that i've spoken about
countless times in videos on my channel
as well as the bioneer
but really the best way to condition
yourself for an exercise or an activity
is just by doing the activity again and
again and again however with one very
big caveat which is that it needs to be
done with a sufficient level of effort
in which you push yourself regularly
but not constantly remember that balance
otherwise you just remain at the level
you're currently at
i actually think this point is one of
the main reasons that many martial
artists have kind of stagnated
at their current level of skill actually
and that's because they've become
accustomed to training at a certain pace
and then when i train with them they get
tired easily and i'm thinking you know
you're supposed to be a martial artist
why are you not fit enough to do the
activity we're doing
not enough intensity and i wanted to
stay away from using this word in the
previous sections talking about power
because power and intensity are actually
two different things although there is
some crossover in the middle
the way i like to think about intensity
is more kind of like a high level view
or
theme that you carry into all of your
training sessions
now obviously there's many different
ways that you can use the bag and i'm
certainly not saying there's only one
way to use it but i am talking in
general terms of just progression here
so if we think about the word intensity
kind of like a container in which all of
your training takes place and within
that container can be many different
elements
you can be really intense without
putting in any power at all and just
work on volume of strikes and speed for
instance or like i mentioned in the
previous section you can be working more
upon developing power with fewer strikes
concentrating on technique body position
and so on but these are both different
examples of intensity
and the same also goes for too much
intent as well to where the person is
not leaving any room for kind of freedom
of expression
and development of their own style by
this i mean constantly executing strikes
without really considering what you're
doing
and i think this is where people end up
looking a bit robotic and
one-dimensional
something that also ties into this area
is actually not hitting the bag
enough to receive the sufficient
conditioning benefits that you could
otherwise get from it so the strikes
you're doing could be decent in power
and technique etc but if they're so few
and far between as i said you won't be
getting the conditioning you would
otherwise get with greater volume
and this leads nicely on to the next
point which is not getting your weight
behind the strikes or you could say kind
of only using your arms to throw the
punches
it's not really about applying power
always it's learning how to apply power
more like
this can be a weird one because again
there's a certain level of understanding
about the mechanics of striking that's
required if people have very limited
experience
but even those with relatively decent
technique otherwise can also fall victim
to this when going onto a bag for
instance
and that's because of the change in
environment meaning that there's now a
great big bag in front of you to contend
with and you have to adapt your
technique from hitting pads or shadow
boxing in order to
work effectively and this is something
that's actually really important that
i've not seen spoken much about
so a decent pad holder should provide
equal resistance to the force of the
punches that you're throwing but even
with a pad holder there's no way that
their arms are going to obviously be
able to resist your strikes as much as
a hard and a decent quality heavy bag so
there's a lot to contend with there
and this is applicable for everything
you do but especially for hook punches
for instance
the bag's much wider obviously than a
person's head or the position in which
your training partner will hold pads for
you
and so you've got to adapt for these
variables and this can only really be
gained through
experience of the bag and finding out
what works it's also going to be
different depending on your specific
body type
so you'll have to find out the best way
for you personally to apply power but
there are some general rules about this
that are applicable globally to take
into account
if you want a greater understanding
about this topic i made a video about
kinetic linking and the mechanics of
striking so
please check the link in the description
this next point ties in with the
previous one i mentioned
and that's been really one dimensional
with almost little to no extra movement
many people just stand in one position
and execute the same strikes and combos
continually when training on the bag
and at the same pace as well with no
rhythm or variation
so one of the purposes of the bag is
learning to strike at different angles
how to move off center line circle an
opponent and things like that and this
can be developed in numerous ways but
the one i would suggest
is in shadow boxing because obviously
you've got the complete freedom to move
around
with no obstacles in your way to kind of
find out what works and develop your own
style you can then take your ideas to
the bag afterwards and try different
things out
also ensuring to utilize different
levels and not always punching at the
same place
all the time this next point is mainly
applicable to those fighting in
competition and that's using
combinations that are unrealistic
or not something that might happen in a
real situation so although we obviously
don't want to have rehearsed routines
that we always fall back on naturally
this is going to happen to an extent
now we all have our go-to techniques no
matter how advanced we are so it pays
for you to train yourself to fall back
on ones that may give you
the opportunity to get the upper hand so
if this point applies to you then do
ensure that you're training some combos
that are naturally going to be quite
realistic
and go with your style of fighting for
instance one of those would be this
simple combo the first three strikes
will cause the opponent to lift their
hands into a covered position leaving an
opening for the fourth body shot to land
in the ribs and subsequently then
leaving them open for the kick
afterwards or
whatever other applicable technique you
want to execute so those were some of
the common mistakes that i've noticed
throughout my time training
that people tend to fall into when using
the heavy bag
and as mentioned before many of these
areas come down to working within that
fine balance and a lot of the mistakes
are actually the opposite of each other
for instance
not enough power and applying constant
power that sweet spot lies right in the
middle and you want to ensure that
you're working within that point
in order to get the most benefits from
your training there's loads of different
things within this topic that i could
have mentioned here
but i just thought these were some of
the most common ones and some of the
most important that i would mention and
highlight
that you want to watch out for in
training and also if you have any other
ideas for subsequent episodes in the
common mistakes series
please let me know in the comments
thanks very much guys and i will see you
next time